hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over Game three from the 2013
World Championship Game three
much more exciting than the first two
games if you recall from the first two
games both of them draws and both of
them lasted just a handful of moves and
moreover even before they really began
so to start Game three we have Magnus
Carlsen playing the white pieces an on
defends with the black pieces Magnus
Carlsen decides to start out with
something similar that we saw in Game
one with be ready opening with a knight
here to f3 again really can transpose
into a lot of different openings which
Magnus Carlsen really likes and we see
very similar we see this pawn to b5 but
as we didn't see before we see this
early push forward with this pawn here
to c4 so right away you can see Magnus
Carlsen looking to change things up
right away didn't really like how the
first game went obviously drawing after
16 moves was not what he wants to do as
the white pieces wants to play a little
bit more aggressive and so that's
exactly what we see after the pawn
coming here to see for the Queen coming
here to a4 pretty much signaled from the
get-go that this was going to be a very
different game than we've seen from the
first two games black now responds
Knight to c6 again kind of blocking the
check getting another piece involved
into the game so we have the bishop here
to g2 again both sides fee and getting
their bishops here on d7 Angie - we've
seen a lot of the you know the hyper
modern defense as far as trying to
control the turn of the board with these
minor pieces we've seen a lot of fee and
getting the bishops to both this g7 and
this g2 square early on into the
tournament now we see Knight to c3 and
this is kind of a you know after the
pawn pushes forward to e7 or to e5 here
this is kind of a reverse Sicilian
dragon so why it's kind of having the
setup of a you know Sicilian defense
dragon style if you will if you're
familiar with that defense and black
kind of has the sinner controlled the
board with it you know his pawn here on
e5 you know he has the fee and head of
Bishop here and do seven kind of
protecting it he also has this night
here on c6 ko
kind of has the roles reversed right now
now from here white decides to go ahead
and take back that material on c4 was
really just going to be taken sooner or
later and so as you can tell from both
sides they are equal in material kind of
going into they're still in book right
now as far as the lines that they're
going after
as an on-set they're not flying blind
yet so all these moves they've kind of
studied up and they're just trying to
figure out the different variations that
they want to play but they're not really
thinking outside of what they've already
prepared for these tournaments at this
point in the game black now brings his
knight to e7 probably a little better
square then you know if we see Knight to
f6 then we can you know white could play
Knight to g5 putting pressure you know
threatening this Queen here to f7
checkmate you know from here you might
see King castling but then after the
bishop coming and you know the pawn
you're capturing the Queen capturing
here on c6 this is just a much tougher
situation for black to be in and so
because of that black can instead
instead of bringing his you know Knight
here to the the common f6 square instead
decides to go ahead and play it here to
this e 7 square this does allow him to
still castle on the King side but still
allows anon to you know protect this
night here on c6 with this Knight here
on these 7 so Magnus is going to go
ahead and castle on the King side and so
we see the same thing from anon here on
the black side and then we see the pawn
coming here to d3 wanting to get this
Bishop outside of the pawn chain get
them involved into the action something
that can be very difficult especially
early on for white is to get this dark
square bishop involved into the action
and now we see pawn here to h6 and then
Bishop here to d2 so Magnus Carlsen has
completed development early on he's
connected his rooks and so he can now go
into the middle game and start to see if
he can find a weakness in Black's
position now the Knights going to come
to d4 and afterwards in the
press-conference Magnus Carlsen said
that he actually wasn't prepared for
this night to d4 kind of caught him off
guard there was a few moves that he
talked about this Knight to d4
what was one of those moves he decides
to just go ahead and take and after
takes that the night just comes over
here to e4 still wants to make sure it's
centralized but it is being attacked so
it does need to move now the pawn comes
to c6 it can you know later on you know
push forward if he wants to an attack
but doesn't want to just kind of keep
this open right here with all his pawns
on a 7 b7 and c7 so now the bishop comes
here to be four this is one of the moves
that you know I think magnus carlsen
somewhat made of a mistake and he even
said after the match that Bishop to b4
was probably not his best move because
the next move from an on right here with
his Bishop to e6 really there's no great
squares for this Queen to come to it you
know it can't come back here it's not
going to come to either of these squares
right here again this pawn on c5 is you
know blocking this outpost here on b5
and it can no longer come over here
because he's kind of blocked by the
bishop so it's kind of forced to retreat
you know kind of back here to c2 or c1
are the only options this would be very
different if you come back and say okay
you know from this position instead of
bringing the bishop here to b4 which
isn't really extremely active right now
unless he just wants to go ahead and
exchange off one of his bishops which
usually don't see too often in a game
with with high-level players but you
could see you know pawn to a4 he still
has some pretty active pieces on the
Queen side and so starting to push
forward with a for both of the King
sides are pretty safe right now but
starting to push forward you know with a
four wall you have active pieces makes a
lot more sense in the particular game
though we see Magnus cross and play this
Bishop here to b4 after the bishop here
to e6 which is a great little move again
getting your pieces involved into the
game and gaining tempo to force your
opponent back now after the Queen comes
back here to c1 now we see Bishop here
to d5 and so if you can to look at this
situation again Black has kind of gone
from this defensive I'm trying to get my
pieces the bottoms of the game all of a
sudden to okay they kind of are
controlling the center of the board and
they're now putting pressure on their
opponents Magnus Carlsen now decides to
play a four
in my opinion it's a little bit later
than he should have he doesn't quite
have as many pieces involved you know
with his Queen back here and c1 this a4
is just not the having as much pressure
as you want onto the game so now we see
a pawn here to b6 getting ready if he
wants to to kind of solidify this entire
pawn chain with b5 also stopping you
know the pawn pushing any further you
know to a5 and now Magnus Carlsen
decides to go ahead and exchange this
Bishop here on e7 with this knight so
going through the rest of the game anons
going to have these double bishop which
can be very very dangerous especially if
an on can kind of open up the board get
a lot of these pawns off the board so
they can pretty much control the entire
board in Magnus Carlsen on the white
side is going to be stuck with a bishop
and a knight which can be very dangerous
in the right circumstance so let's go
further the queen is going to recapture
no real other move now the pawn comes to
a5 after the Queen is moved doesn't
quite have the defenders so the rooks
now going to come to b8 obviously you
don't want to just take right away and
so now the works going to swing over to
e1 again more likely to push this epon
up then he is this F pawn especially
with both the bishops on the board you
know if they centralize that dark square
Bishop that's going to start to put a
lot of pressure so you want to make sure
that you have some Keeney side safety so
now we see the rook swing over to c8
again black really has more of the pawns
on the Queen side so we can really start
to push if you wanted to with that Queen
side advantage with his pawns so now we
see after the pawn takes in the pawn
recaptures right here we kind of look at
again both sides still equal in material
so it's still fairly even black still
kind of dominates the center of the
board but white does control this a file
which can be extremely important and
white really needs to get you know as
pieces a little bit more active this
knight in the center is very good its
Queen on c1 is not doing a whole lot
both sides have you know safe safe Kings
so all in all a fairly equal game right
now now we see the Queen comes to f4
again pretty centralized square no real
other places for the Queen to go to
so you know this does make some sense
now we have the route coming over here
to d8 now we have to keep in mind that
this Bishop here right now is not so
much protected by this rook because if
this rook swings down here then the
Queen can swing up here and take this
rook on b8 so that's something just to
keep in mind this bishops not being
attacked right now but it's something
the Magnus Carlsen could look - do you
know if he moves this Knight anywhere he
then could take the bishop and the
bishop
you know this pawn would have to take
back and there would be doubled pawns
because again the rook could not take
back right away because it's inherently
protecting both this rook a Miss Bishop
and this rook here on b8 would fall so
just some things to think about as far
as Magnus Magnus Carlsen is looking at
the board he does have some tactics that
he can really get into if his opponent
falls into a mistake now the pawns going
to push forward to h4 which I really
like again we've already talked about
that an on has the Queen side advantage
he has more pawns over here it's going
to be easy for him to attack you know he
can always swing his queen over here to
b4 if he wants to be pretty aggressive
you know really attack this pawn here on
b2 so Magnus Carlsen recognizes this and
says you know if I'm gonna have any sort
of counter play more than likely it's
going to be on the King side and so he
decides to go ahead and start pushing
forward with h4 and now we see the King
come here to h7 again wants to have some
sort of protection again if pieces start
falling off you want to also have your
king near the center of the board going
into the endgame and now we see Knight -
D - I probably would have preferred
seeing something you know pawn to h5
again if you're going to attack the the
King side you know you can always
continue with that now we could see the
pawn push forward with g5 and then you
know the Queen comes back here to c1 but
again this is going to be a nice little
square for this pawn here on h5 and then
again later
you know Magnus Carlsen is threatening
some pieces you can always give these
other pieces involved into the game but
this pawn here on h5 is definitely to be
a good square unfortunately decides to
play out consider more of a passive move
plays this Knight to d2 but it does also
open up what we're talking about
the bishop takes here on d5 and then you
know this rook here on the ADA is is
protected by this this rook here on on
d8 so instead you know we see an on play
a nice little move centralizing his dark
squared Bishop attacking this Queen so
no longer has to worry this this rook is
now free to protect this bishop here
forcing this Queen back and now after
the pawn on h5 which again a white my
guess is probably wanted to have his
pawn there and you can take it back but
now forces the Queen come to back here
to h3
and then after the bishop here on each
six on e6 again just forcing back this
this Queen here on h1 if you have a
queen you typically don't want to have
it in the corner of the board being
trapped by a pawn structure and your
bishop now it does have a you know
bishop in front of it so we can kind of
attack but then I can just play this
pawn to c5 which he does and then all of
a sudden you know you have this barrel
but it's not really attacking anything
and in this case you just have a queen
that's not doing much so if we look at
the board and on is definitely winning
the game at this moment he has a much
more active position he has the double
bishop pair which can be extremely
dangerous both of his rooks are
completely active his queen is much more
involved into the game it's not in the
corner on h1 so things are definitely
looking at for black so now we see the
knight come to e4 again it moved back to
the 2 and now it sets efore the king is
going to come over here to g7 wants to
make sure that it can't fall to any
checks you know by Knight here to to g5
or any of that but the Knights going to
come here to g5 no longer in check and
Anand just decides to start pushing
forward again he has that Queen side
advantage that we talked about with the
pond so he's going to kind of push that
and then we see pawn here to e3 then
after the capture the Brooks is going to
swing up here to to e3 this is one of
those cases where you know I feel like
an on really needs to just take this
pawn here on b2 afterwards that was one
of the the most asked questions from
people in the gallery after the match
you can ask questions to annona and
Carlson and everyone was kind of curious
you know why black didn't take this pawn
here on b2 it was just kind of hanging
out there for Magnus Carlsen even seemed
questioned that you know why he didn't
think this pawn was taken anon said he
couldn't find any good continuation as
far as he thought white had good
compensation for this but but all in all
I think Bishop takes on b2 is completely
safe and obviously gains material going
into the endgame you could just start
exchanging pieces off especially since
you kind of have all the momentum with
your bishops I think that would have
been better in the particular game
though just decides to play Bishop to b4
centralizing his bishop but again not
doing too much and after the rook came
to e2 you know I thought there may be
another opportunity later on to attack
but decided to go ahead and you know
halt that right now decides to instead
push forward with his pawns and now we
see the knight take in the bishop here
on e6 so black no longer has the double
Bishop here but still has a very active
Bishop here on before and after the pawn
takes here this also allows you know
black to bring is rook over here to f8
and then there's now you know two
attackers with that Bishop and the rook
here on f2 so that's definitely
something that the non can come to later
on if you wants to now we see the bishop
come here to e4 again centralizing this
Bishop again it's not really attacking
anything else on the board so getting it
away from this square here on g2 is is
definitely good so we see the Pontic and
now the rook swing over here to d2 and
now the Queen comes in to b4 starting to
put some more pressure on the Queen side
which we already talked about and now
this works going to swing over to d1 and
then we see the bishop take on b2
could have also played you know
something else did have some other
options could have swung over here if
you wanted to on you know f8 right away
but but good that he's actually taking
the material that you probably should
have taken awhile ago now the queen is
going to come to f3 wants to get more
involved again being
h1 was not doing a whole heck of a lot
of anything so definitely something
that's magnus carlsen what needed to do
now brings the bishop back here to f6
kind of blocking stuff off and then we
see you know the rook take here again
black is still up in material he does
have this pawn advantage so it's going
to be very important for a nod to
actually take advantage of this and then
the rook takes here and then we see the
rook recapture and then the rooks gonna
swing over to d8 and this is kind of one
of those points in the game where I feel
like an on had the advantage he looked
at it and then again even in the
questions afterwards he said he didn't
want to get too tactical in the game my
guess is he thinks Magnus Carlsen may be
a better tactical player but he had
bishop here to d4 this is a great
centralizing square for this bishop you
know he can always push forward with
pawn to e5 really having a nice little
outpost just dominating the center of
the board
both of these are on dark squares so
this bishop here this light square
bishop is not going to have any sort of
pressure on this this is going to be
very good also blocks off a lot of
mobility for this rook here on d3 this
rook if you wants to control anything is
going to have to move a couple squares
he's going to have to come back here you
know to 2 d1 and then kind of move
around it's going to be awkward you know
when again from black standpoint he can
move this rook around the board again
he's probably going to want to play this
pawn to e5 it is being protected by the
Queen right now but again just
solidifying the center of the board I
think this was an easy find I'm not
really sure why I'm not decided not to
do it instead in the game he actually
decided to play look to d8 which in my
opinion as you'll see later on to the
game this is a varied relish move this
pretty much gives up in my opinion all
of the momentum and the goodness that
black had in the game so from here why
decided to go ahead and take and then
after the bishop took bishop now comes
down to d3 the Queen came over to the
fore again that just kind of saying hey
I'm going to centralize my piece but I'm
just going to give back the materia
that I was up I don't even want to try
to attempt to hold on to it and so both
sides uh you know are pretty much even
going into the in game that there's no
real advantage that either side has you
know and so as we kind of go forward you
know Anand wants to just go ahead and
trade off pieces if you can magnus
carlsen decides he doesn't want to have
a more active King right now you know if
you were to take right away this would
definitely be bad for magnus carlsen you
know it takes him a few moves to get his
King involved where the King right here
on f6 is a lot more involved into the
game so decides to go ahead and play
this Queen here to b7 and then kind of
forwarding this attack with Bishop here
to e7 but again this Bishop can't move
anymore and so a few moves magnus
carlsen decides to get his King involved
into the action a little bit more than a
few moves later and now the exchange of
Queens and then again both sides really
just don't have a lot of material left
everyone was kind of waiting for them to
just shake hands and then a few moves
later they decide to go ahead and in the
game right here insufficient material
for checkmate and so after 51 moves we
have a draw now the good news is is two
things in my opinion one is we actually
got to move 51 which is a lot more than
we've gotten even from the first two
games combined in also if you've seen
the players demeanor after the matches
they really look like they want to win
Magnus Carlsen looks really frustrated
that he could not come up with a better
plan and actually win especially as
white he's now played white two times so
I feel like these players want to win
I'm excited that in game 3 they actually
tried for the win and said the first two
games where they just kind of move their
pieces and then shook hands and then had
an early dinner they actually tried in
this game in my opinion so I'm hoping
that's the next few games are going to
be exciting and will actually have some
wins across the across the board because
those are always good so hopefully you
guys enjoyed Game three hopefully this
is a sign of good things to come in the
future
and I'll see you all in the next one
thanks for watching